the thing that is stopping everyone is
fear the fear that most stops people is
the fear of other people's judgments
whether it is therapy which I think is
profoundly effective for so many people
whether it is the limitation this is a
big one this is a favorite of mine
because it's working whether it is the
limitation of the people around you that
you love that bring negativity on the
hour every day every week every year not
the cutting out not calling Mom and
saying [__] you Mom you're negative I'm
never talking to you again no instead of
talking to your negative Mom twice a day
you talk to her once every two weeks
because cutting is not practical
Vayner Nation live from New York City
city office we're in Orchard Street I'm
really excited about this fun fun fun
thing to uh uh set up here
2020 we did a garyvee challenge I'm
scared because people love consuming
information but they hate doing the
things in the information I am now
challenging you my audience to make
content at scale and I'm gonna pick some
winners in January of the people that
have gone out and actually made that I
put out to the community about making it
was behind the deck and the content I
think it's well documented for my three
guests and many of the people listening
we uh believe in content output we
believe that the doing matters it's kind
of like in the content world it's
similar to the working out physical
fitness world you can read about
push-ups and eating well but you kind of
actually have to do it to get the
benefits of it and we we did this
contest we said we'd pick a couple of
winners have them on the podcast and
then I don't know if you guys and gals
remember but there was this thing it was
called covid kind of threw us for a loop
uh and you know one thing I'm proud of
is I juggle a lot of balls with that
means is certain things fall but the
intent is always to deliver on all balls
in the air this was one that was in here
and here we are three years later and uh
our three winners are with me uh we are
at p t Studios podcast studios here in
New York City which by the way Serge
correct me if I'm wrong who's up behind
the one two three and fours
um creators can come through here and do
the podcast right it's a bookstore
podcast combo
um yeah and it's free so how do they do
how do they do that do they just go to
the website or just roll the [__] into
the bookstore go to our website and
click on podcasts in the menu tab and
it'll take you to everything you need to
know about the store and how to sign up
so I'm excited because it's a
win-win-win kind of day I like when a
lot of people win number one the global
audience of aspiring podcasters that are
listening to this right now should
really come to the studio and the three
individuals that we're on right now I'm
excited for them to share their stories
that's a win and me and my team
delivering on our word that feels good
like things on my chest that's a win so
a lot of winning going around speaking
of winning why don't we go around uh to
the three individuals let them introduce
themselves ladies first to my left
okay
say hello tell us a little bit about you
my name is Katie Masters nice to meet
you nice to meet you also known as nail
thoughts on Instagram and all the other
social media platforms and I like
Myspace like when you say older like no
oh yeah
Myspace Tumblr I love it
um and I started doing nails in 2015. I
actually opened my own private Salon
space it's literally a little smaller
than this space and yeah and it's just
me and I just grew my clientele with
reviews and Word of Mouth not as much it
was more like reviews just reviews
online reviews and then Yelp yep I don't
know I don't know if that's a California
thing or what but it's so funny every
time I'm somewhere else I'm like oh I'll
write a Yelp review they're like I'll
write a Google review
what's going on but uh that's how I grew
my business
um and I had to stop taking clients
because it was just I was booked six
weeks out and then from then on I think
I was just going did you ever consider I
apologize did you ever consider raising
prices I did yeah because I did it
multiple times yeah for everyone who's
listening I hear that a lot that's why I
just jumped in to give everybody value a
lot of you are you're the person that
makes the money the lawyer the the lawn
mower like the like you're doing the
thing the service when the correct when
you are hitting capacity yes you could
always do more but then there's a
burnout for all of us regardless well
that's 30 hours a week 70 hours a week
there is a threshold it's raising prices
that help you grow your business if you
choose to do that obviously there's a
million ways to expand products and
services totally and so yeah I did raise
my prices a few times and then
eventually I just went so hard with
social media I didn't know why I didn't
have a goal but it was very much in the
Heyday of Instagram like it was just
everything was hitting it was just back
in the day and then
I think I just build my community up so
well that a gel brand that I loved
cocois reached out to me and they were
like do you want to have a gel line with
us and so we have this collaboration and
it's amazing and then the pandemic
happened and I shut down and I started
doing press-ons like hand painting yeah
crazy and I would make you know 60 sets
at a time and for a month and then I
would put it for sale and it would sell
out in like under four minutes it was
crazy it was so great and I think just
launching the colors and the press-ons I
just was like dude I love this I love
launching stuff I love marketing stuff I
love selling stuff yeah me too and so I
think that's kind of where I'm at right
now is like an awkward transition of
maybe stepping away from doing nails and
continuing to do my clients listening or
like what did she say they're like what
but it's very much like maybe like the
rock or you know in wrestling you come
out of retirement once in a while and
just like do it see there's like some
cool stuff you can do yeah that's
awesome let's keep going to the left
that's a great starting point way to
give us that context I'm sure that
resonates with a lot of people 100 uh
Colin dark
c-o-l-i-n-d-a-r-k-e I'm the amidextrous
artist I've uh been drawing and creating
artwork my entire life since I was five
really and uh in 2019 especially
prompted by The garyvee Challenge I
started producing more and more content
on social media and a lot of my drawings
just took off and got viral on Tick Tock
and Instagram and YouTube and so I've
had a lot of fun with that I'm also an
attorney and compliance professional so
I was kind of balancing doing all that
at once and just two weeks ago I left my
corporate job where I helped build up a
fintech over eight years and now I'm
just doing my own individual law
practice and Consulting business
kind of leveraging everything I've
learned over the years to help smaller
startups and clients and I'm trying to
transition or integrate that into my
social media
you know by social media presence they
kind of right yeah you're putting out
more other legal and compliance content
not just the drawing right yeah it's
awesome so I'm just starting that now it
makes sense that's what two weeks and I
started yeah I just came up with a logo
and had people kind of vote which logo
they like the best for Colin dark
Solutions and join this uh little
entrepreneurial like startup law firms
I'm the sixth attorney with the firm and
it's called go with canvas and it feels
like the startup culture from when I
first started the business I was in
which is when I had the most fun because
I was wearing tons of different hats
yeah I was able to help marketing I was
able to like share all my ideas with
every aspect of the business and then as
we grew it was like no no no yeah you're
uh you're the attorney yep and I've
never been just the attorney I I just
clearly don't like that you draw right
right so you've got to create you've got
the gray and the black and white you've
got them both yeah and I've got to um I
have to do them all all the time so if I
shut one thing off it's like it's not
good for me like it like I start slowing
down with all things yep so
um the more I could just run towards
something that fills me with joy which
is like creating something versus kind
of like something that was depleting it
a little the more energized I am so the
more I will do with these different
businesses and with my art so I love it
brother thank you
my man take us home beautiful so uh my
name is Drew c
um I am at least in this context rapper
musician
um my good brother Faron and I shout out
to the black OC uh we at the beginning
of 2020
at the behest of Gary actually
he had a conversation with the legend
nipsy hustle about three years ago and
he made a very bold prediction saying
there will be a big time artist in the
next decade that puts out a song a day
I'm telling you right now somebody's
gonna wake up and do something called
365. I know you're starting [__]
January 1st and they're gonna [__] go
that within the next decade someone's
gonna come out and they're going to make
a song a day just the the nature of
content to contextualize the
conversation you were saying there's
there's too much opportunity for someone
not to that's right and so Farren
actually came to me with a suggestion
let's blow that out of the water let's
make a song and a music video every day
love and so we started on January 1st
365 2020. that was our that was our
mission and we got the whole community
in Orange County behind us all the all
the creatives all the musicians all the
producers we had a real large communal
movement towards actualizing that that
vision
in large part just to say hey Gary's
right and the opportunity is there so
why not be the ones that capitalize on
it and go for it I flew out I moved my
whole life from Denver out to Orange
County we rolled for about three months
covet hit and then we we got about three
months more we got today 187 and
after George Floyd died yes fahren
really felt this deep cause to go and
document that so he actually went and
made an amazing documentary called bang
for change everybody go check that out
it's it's a really really powerful
visual representation of what was
happening on the ground both
um in Orange County and all across the
country at that time he put a lot of
really really good work into that
amazing and it felt like at that point
the the movement shifted yeah so I've
been continuing to make music that's
really the the core passion that I have
is to be a Creator and to use my voice
to to tell stories and to speak and to
connect with other people's stories
beyond that we've we've started a
retreat company we run Retreats around
the world we have one of the biggest
Wellness Retreat companies in the world
at this point that we've started and are
pushing that I'm a people person so a
lot of what 365 taught me was more you
know the creative side of me is for me
but there's a lot of me that I was I was
actually withholding and so it's it's
transitioned me now people skills to
operationalize it to do something
exactly makes sense and to give people
the inspiration to for them to do that
same thing too yeah it makes sense
because I think a lot of people feel
that and so now I've got my hands in a
couple pots like the the music is always
cooking it's always there yeah of course
always coming out with new content on
that front and then yeah being able to
really bring people together in a more
communal format to really focus on their
well-being their mental health their
spiritual well-being so that they can go
out and produce whatever they need to
produce to be in that same inspirational
level that's where I'm at now all right
well to that point in our little
four-person family here for the rest of
this hour
um I want to be here for you as much as
possible that's the most interesting
part for me so why don't we go back
around the horn
and why don't you fire away with some
questions because I think your questions
are many millions of people's questions
that over the next three decades this
will be consumed by and so
um and a lot of them are Universal and
some of them are contextual
um you know there'll be a time where
people will listen to this and be like
what was covet yeah you know that's just
how the world works you know and so um
but I'd love to answer anything anything
very narrow anything very broad so let's
fire away
um
I mean I mainly have two
sort of questions the first one would be
you know as I transition away from
services to yourself and doing Services
um
I don't know I guess the main thing I'm
worried about is so many people followed
me for nails and the art yeah and
posting oh here watch me do this watch
me do these nails and do you have that
same audience after you move it on them
yeah instead of putting out content for
them now you're selling them something
and that changes the relationship as
well yeah and by the way the the
handsome gentleman to the left of you is
going to go through that as well now
right you have an audience following you
for drawing and now you're talking about
legal [__] and by the way the old man in
the middle here went through it as well
I built my career for five years on
talking about wine and then just one day
said I'm gonna talk about business and
marketing now and everyone's like what
so couple things
you you can fear the fact that there's a
start over you can fear that you're not
going to get as many listens and Views
you can fear that you'll get comments
that are like you're a sellout or I miss
the old you but what you must fear the
most is when you want to do something
that is in your soul and stomach
staying for them versus going for you
will make you the most
unhappy it will bring the worst out of
everything and so unfortunately it's
just the way it is as humans if you stay
for the wrong reasons
even when those seemingly are wonderful
traits of being loyal or trying to do
the right thing by somebody that right
by you it is not sustainable yeah so
what you need to do is everyone who goes
through this journey needs to put their
ego on the Shelf
they need to lean into humility they
need to lead lean into the joys of the
early days of starting at zero
and so like yeah I mean you'll and you
know this even the way you were talking
about Instagram you've already lived
through things changing with platforms
that have nothing to do with your
content there are Ebbs and flows and
times where you're getting more views
than ever then you're more viral than
ever even think about sports and music
like there's just sometimes you're on
and bad like you're having a good season
and other times you're not music you can
go through 24 months where you're as big
as anybody in the world and then like
you can go three years and people like
forgot that you like they hear your song
and they're like yo what happened to
like you know like you know Three Six
Mafia even though they're Legends like
it's just the way it is it's just the
way it is so I think you need to lean
into a Zen place of I know I am doing
this and it came earlier the way you
talked about selling [__] you're there
Katie I know so like yeah it may hurt it
may not do as well your first post a
couple years ago or a year ago or
whatever might do better than future
ones because it was the first time you
ever sold anything you built up so much
Equity people some people just bought
that [__] just to support you because
they've been enjoying you so much but
then balance of like what you give
versus what you take it changes all of
that's okay all of it's appropriate I
think you just need to realize it's
going to be a slog
or it might not be because it's not like
you're doing what Paul and I did you're
not going so far away totally it's not
like you're now selling like you know
tires right exactly I'm like guess what
everybody so I think what you what
you're probably worried about is you
inherently know already it's harder to
get views than it was when you blew up
and now you're gonna tweak it and that
probably is going to compound that don't
don't live for the algorithm live for
your happiness yeah you understand yeah
like being uh you know being associated
with likes and followers dictating what
you make is really one of the big
vulnerabilities right now in the Creator
economy people are people are like
showing too much I mean I really worry
for people that are attractive but both
boys and girls hit me up pretty often
about like
yo how do I stop showing my [__] you
know boobs and ass and chest and like
pecs and six-pack like I'm not that
person anymore but every time I try to
go into anything else I'm like listen
your audience came for the visual
modeling and now you want to talk about
like you know origami like there's gonna
be a transition but you can't keep
showing your skin because you addicted
to the likes you've moved on and want to
talk about being a barber yeah you know
yeah so you're just gonna have to deal
with the transition but you're gonna
find a new audience my audience is
bigger than ever because of where I went
even though it was a hard reset yeah
and then what are your thoughts on this
is just my second question so the gel
line I have it's continuing to expand
it's a professional gel line right so
half of my audience is
gel nail techs nail salons professionals
makes sense
um and then if I were to relaunch
pressons for example completely
different audience so I'm kind of stuck
on well remember the days of the content
we're all consuming being based on who
we follow is changing yeah so for years
I've been pushing do everything on your
channel and everyone would always get
mad at me yet the algorithms did the
work for me as we all know
it's thou no longer social media acting
like an email newsletter where everyone
sees everything you post it's the
content is the variable of what people
see yeah so you'll be able to actually
post both yeah I'm like worried about
the mixed messaging because will that
[__] up the algorithm it's right the
content is the variable if if literally
if you were put out in if you put out
800 pieces of content as a barber about
being a barber and your next post is
about you rock climbing and and talking
about like the protein bar you ate if
that's a great rock climbing protein bar
post it has the potential to do better
than any free post you've ever had the
algorithm is not penalizing you per se
for doing something different yes in the
first early seconds if your audience
doesn't engage as much there may be some
things but it also may lead to the thing
that you should be doing just like you
said serendipitously found from your
music to wait a minute I'm actually
something else like you you're not going
to get as penalized as you think if
nothing else do it for a year and see
what it feels like yeah more than ever
social media is about the individual
piece of content versus staying to the
things that you always needed to talk
about right it's very much I get stuck
and like oh I've been posting this all
the time and then it's very much like
okay well this is for professionals and
then oh also I know the professionals
won't buy this but here's another
product for people that just want
press-on nails It's all under the same
umbrella which is great but you should
do it both there and I also think like
once every 20 times you should do just
one post about you talking about both
parts of the world yeah it's like a nice
reference point might be a good pinned
for you yeah or a pinned post yeah now
that we have that like top left corner
of your of your main accounts as for
people that are in Social creative every
day probably are following with what I'm
saying you may want to have one
Manifesto video as a matter of fact in
general that's probably a good strategy
for most people the top left pinned post
for everyone should probably be a
long-form video kind of giving everyone
a what's up here yeah I think that
actually we might have cr we might be
crazy creating the movement of a
standard practice right now because it
actually makes a lot of sense it does
everyone's top left pin post should
actually be a recap video of what's up
yeah like here's what you'll see here
here's what you can expect from me
here's what I'm about and this is me I
like that I like it me too awesome
yeah I like it
um well that was a lot but I was yeah it
makes sense yeah uh when I was yours is
a much harder turn yeah yeah and I've
got I've gone off on like showing
different sides of my personality they
do get like hate sometimes yeah like
it's a drawing yeah yeah especially yeah
something it's like I came here for the
drawing yeah it's like well you're going
there of course yeah and opinions are
like and possibly hard for us human
beings to handle that we're incapable of
handling an opinion from someone that
isn't ours and it goes into my DMs and
stuff and it's like all right so like
this is getting rid of some people that
I don't really want following me anyways
and hopefully the people that appreciate
it I'm not gonna I'm not actually I'm
not to actually use you but I'm gonna
level it up and I just want to hear this
I actually think in Collins
important statement that I want to tag
on to because I want to bring dolly in
this podcast
look I think we all know what we're
talking about you know subtly talking
about here whether it's politics social
issues there's a lot going on
this concept of
people being mad at you and no longer
following you because they don't agree
with something that you said being
people that you didn't want following
you anyway I think it's something we
need to challenge and I'm not again I'm
not it's just normal talk I'm alone and
by the way and by the way I'm sure I've
said it as well so it's not even about
that it's just a fun combo that I'd like
to bring up just quick little commercial
break I really think we need to think
about that that is the point of the joke
I made prior a minute ago which is like
we need the only way out of this anxiety
that everyone's feeling is we need to
get back to the capacity to have some
form of Civility and empathy for
understanding why someone doesn't see it
your way we have to like for me some of
my friends have I'm aware whether
they're to the left or the right why
they don't see something the same way as
me because their mom or grandmother both
raised them and like we're really about
XYZ I'm not even going to go into the
specifics but we need to get back to
like having compassion for and to your
point column is why I jumped in I'm not
mad at the nasty the nastiest stuff that
gets sent to me I'm trying to have
compassion for
um but to your point man it hurts like
when you are getting really railed on
like and sometimes scare I mean I think
guys have it better than girls like
girls DMS get really scary because guys
on tilt to women are like anybody on
tilt like women on women men on men is
always bad but guys on tilt to women
sometimes go into really uncomfortable
places yeah very dark and so like in
general we need to have if someone has
the capacity to go dark on you they're
not in a good place uh by the way now
I'm like it's so funny I just realized
why I'm saying this in the last 72 hours
and Sid is in the room right now and Sid
and I got a very interesting DM from
Twitter about six months or a year ago
from somebody apologizing for something
that was really detrimental to me and I
don't want to go any further but like a
real heartfelt apology and at the end
was I was just in a bad place and I was
using you
uh in the last 72 hours I got two more
of those not to the same level
of the one that I'm referring to with
Sid one was solid I remember it one very
honestly I don't really remember so it
was kind of minor both apologizing in DM
for doing bad things and using me and
both ending with you know explaining the
justification you know just in a very
dark place in my life I was in a bad
place in my life it is just so clear
that the people that are sending the
nastiest stuff are not in a great place
and it is on us
anyone who's not I'm in a super great
place so I'm doing who I'm doing but a
lot of us are just neutral wouldn't say
we're remarkable wouldn't say that we're
[__] dark yeah I think all of us in
the middle
have to look in the mirror and say I
need to choose bright because it feels
like the middle decided to choose dark
in the last seven to ten years and so
everyone in the middle if you're just
kind of like okay not loving life but
not like [__] hating it that you want
to go around and [__] threaten people
and [__] on people
you just choose 2024 like well I'll give
you a lot of time I'll give you the
January 1st can you rewind this six
months in a row and just like can you
choose in 2024 to just choose light
instead of dark I think that could
really help anyway I apologize I wanted
that tangent but I just realized why
because
man it really hurts like you know like
like and it's you know and what people
think is like everything everyone says
is like intended to hurt them and it's
not P everyone's sharing everyone we're
all kind of equal in our opinions
like it's your opinion and like of
course there's a moral right or wrong
people's moral right and Wrongs are
different too like it's a wild world we
just need to be a little more optimistic
and a little bit more empathetic yeah
rant over go ahead brother no no I
appreciate that and that is kind of one
of my mottos is just bring Sunshine yeah
I do focus on that's how I show up so
can I give you a piece of advice that
would be epic for your soul epic oh yeah
yes the next DM you get that's really
nasty like [__] you for saying that I'm
unfollowed no [__] audio reply and
DM and be like hey Johnny I get it and
like [__] the world right like because
nobody this person loved you at some
point or liked you at some point yeah
you know follow me right I get it and
like I get it like it's it's it's
acknowledging that everyone gets it hey
I get it like I'm sorry to go I respect
that I wish you nothing but good on your
future Trails I just want you to know
that I saw this and I appreciate that
you ever followed me or that you ever
got value for my drawings and I wish you
well I'm telling you
that's a big deal and it will work for
you and of course I'm sure you could be
this makes sense I'm saying this for the
hundreds of thousands that are listening
in the short window in the millions over
the next years it will be good and
you'll like it and it's good and you'll
leave a good deposit for yourself and
the world it's like humanizes you too
because then you're not just like they
comment and not thinking that you're
just like an anonymous person oh yeah
sometimes with some of the negativity I
like go like paragraphs about where I'm
coming from now just so real quick on
that that's where I like notice how I
said audio versus written word the other
day yeah the other thing I've learned
it's good for everybody audio allows you
to create tone yeah written word if the
person's in a bad place they're gonna
read it in a very different voice than
you wrote it in
remember what's dangerous about the
written word is the person is actually
reading it in their mindset not in your
intended volume and Nuance I have that
with someone that uh one of my team
members and she would bring in emails
she's like can you believe they emailed
me this like read it like you're happy
and you're doing it oh wait yeah it's
not that bad it's like okay how dare
they yeah it's really like why I like
audio and video yeah my company we had a
we had an interesting meeting yesterday
with all 2000 employees we had to talk
about like something that's not going
well in the company where people are
kind of doing the wrong thing but I knew
if I sent it as an email people would be
scared and it would become this thing
and I knew if I could do it on video in
real time like I could impose my intent
and my energy which I think made it land
ten thousand times better so for all the
leaders here before you send a group
email to your 15 employees your nine
employees or 17 employees all your
customers consider a video or audio
because you might be able to get your
point across dramatically better because
it has the nuances versus you being at
the vulnerability of where that person
is in their mind at the time of reading
and again back to the anxiety in the
world 15 years ago the email was less
scary there's more people on tilt and
anxious today and looking for a gotcha
and all that and so the written word is
more vulnerable today than ever before
for people that are trying to
communicate certain things so keep that
in mind
yes
um as I'm tilting towards this uh focus
on representing fintechs and small
companies and kind of you're one of my
like ideal clients yes so when you're
assessing going with a small Law Firm or
a consultant like what goes through your
mind and like what's like I buy from
people
and so this is why I love you you're
about to explore the world of LinkedIn
so my intuition is no I could be wrong
but I'm going to guess here that you
weren't like overly focusing as LinkedIn
as your primary place to share your
drugs
no no right so now here we are so what's
really rad for you because you seem very
curious and creative kind of more of my
mold you're about to get serious about
getting good at LinkedIn because
LinkedIn will be your entire and I mean
massive driver Business Development and
for someone like me if if it became on
my radar through an introduction through
it cold email through a cosign from
someone or through a piece of social
media the first place I would go is to
LinkedIn to see what your presence is
and if I have 49 videos and I'd be like
oh I like this guy he seems like really
like like you you know your demeanor
it's already good it's like you've got a
good demeanor for a lawyer do you know
what I mean well this is a good
juxtaposition I like this tone
um so I think for you what you don't
need to do is put out the video or
written word or even like if you're
doodling or Draw you're you're as much
more than doodling if you're drawing
while you're talking about issues or
opportunities that'd be really rad like
especially because you could draw like a
lawyer yelling at someone or office
fintech or SAS company like yeah you
know it may seem nerdy but it's not
nerdy for the person that's trying to
make a decision right for everyone who's
listening right now A fintech's or
consultancy like that's not cool it's
not cool until you need it like like
nothing's like like very few things are
cool music fashion like we know what's
cool but like many of us buy things that
aren't cool like insurance is not cool
but like Geico has those Geico like you
know and like Flow from Progressive and
like State Farm they exist to make you
buy their insurance because it's not fun
or interesting or cool but everybody
who's just listening probably has State
Farm or Geico or Progressive because of
those three characters right so
um I just thought that Harrison Ford
just walked into the bookstore but I was
wrong but he really did slip like me I
was like Han Solo's here
you see me like oh my God I see it uh
anyway so I think linkedin's gonna
become huge for you and I think you know
um that would be the decision tree for
me and for a lot of people people more
and more back to Yelp the evolution of
Yelp and Google reviews is social think
about everybody in this room just with
head knots like now when you're thinking
about going to a restaurant or taking a
trip or buying something think about how
much more now you search on Tick Tock or
Instagram or YouTube than you did five
or seven years ago that used to be
Google owned that [__] that is not where
people go as much anymore and now ai's
coming and so like content content
content
man soak all that in for a second yeah
so my question is is kind of it it came
up as we were going through that because
what you're talking about about like the
state of the world and the need to
choose the most positive and the most
light that's really like what I lean on
as a person I feel very passionate about
and you know what's unfortunate I'm
sorry to jump in when people here choose
positive they think they're being
delusional right okay I don't want to do
that I need to keep it real I'm like you
mean real negative like I'm keeping it
real if
I see a lot of good well especially with
the state of the world right because
that anxiety can actually fuel where
people come from in their perspective I
think that's what they want and it's
funny I don't believe in like the
Illuminati or the Matrix I really I just
don't when I say they it's just the
collective of people that are all it's
just momentum yes we have a momentum of
negativity
right so in in that right in this
momentum of negativity I I
wholeheartedly believe in the the need
for individuals to choose to not be
caught in that wave yes and I also see
the difficulty especially when it comes
to creators because there is this box
that you can kind of put yourself in
where I'm the nail person or I'm the
drawing person or I'm the music person I
ran into this in 365. one of the biggest
challenges for me personally was I got
to the point where I had this idea in my
head of what success was right this is
what being a successful musician is
going to look like feel like be like and
I got to the point where I had it I had
people who were like very invested in
the process and who were very kind in
their feedback they would always provide
me their energy but it wasn't what I
expected so I felt disappointed a little
bit and I think a lot of people feel
that a little bit when they get to the
point where they're like wait I kind of
made it but it's not the thing I thought
it was going to be and I don't know if I
can necessarily change it into the thing
now that actually needs to honor me and
my soul so this is kind of a long-winded
question how I'm putting it together but
you're painting a very clear picture
including one of my favorite subject
matters where which is expectations
always lead to very vulnerable
Frameworks yes especially when you have
expectations of others
my question here is when you're looking
at the world as it is where where
content is kind of the driver now yes
and it's not this one and always has
been the newspaper the radio the
television was the driver content has
always dictated everything the words out
of your mother's mouth in your house
it is the way the world works so what's
different is it's democratized to allow
anyone to hit scale that we had never
seen before so individual content in
that sense individual humans have the
capacity now to hit the scale that
countries used to have the ability to
that's profound that's called the
internet that's scale and so when you
have that that realistic experience for
an individual you could actually have
your message shared and it and for a lot
of people I think where they get scared
is well I don't want it to put me in a
box the way I share it and there is this
negative momentum in the world and so I
have to stick to being as positive as
possible but I don't want to put myself
in this box my question for you would be
when you are looking at individuals
right none of us are in a box we all
have so many different talents and
skills and perspectives and a lot of
beauty we can offer yes
the insecurity that stops people from
doing that and from actually being in
the whole self their whole self not just
a little piece of their self what is
your advice to those people who who know
it's there but who just can't
necessarily pull it out of themselves in
a way they can show it to start working
and putting in the work on the
elimination of fear the thing that is
stopping everyone is fear the fear that
most stops people is the fear of other
people's judgments more than the fear of
not having money which isn't which is
like profoundly interesting because one
money has a level of practicality the
other one is a boogeyman
so to answer your question whether it is
therapy which I think is profoundly
effective for so many people but has a
cost associated with it
whether it is the limitation this is a
big one this is a favorite of mine
because it's working got got one a text
last night I won't use last name Rachel
big shout out to you I love your text at
midnight last night she pointed to a
piece of content that touches on what
I'm about to say and it's changed her
life whether it is the limitation
of the people around you that you love
that bring negativity on the hour
every day every week every year not the
cutting out not calling Mom and saying
[__] you Mom you're negative I'm never
talking to you again no instead of
talking to your negative Mom twice a day
you talk to her once every two weeks
the limitation
because cutting is Not Practical if
rather
there's negative energy in your life
it's unlikely that you're gonna sit here
hear me say this and never talk to your
brother again nor is it right
the limitation gets you to a stable
place which then allows you to go back
to that person on offense and try to get
them into a good place the cutting out
forever does nothing you still made it
the continuation of consuming it at the
scale you're consuming it does nothing
because you're not getting to a sound
Place yourself to be able to help them
the limitation limiting
the energy that you're taking from your
loved ones or closest people on
negativity is a massive way to get to
where you want that you just asked
Health on the physical side
exercise eating better is a driver to
people getting there as well
and then my favorite which is when you
limit number two the negative and you
expand the positive putting positivity
in your ears is a massive game just like
the negativity that was put in your head
by your parents by your teachers by your
best friends by your significant other
by your husband by Your Wife by your
boyfriend by your girlfriend by your two
co-workers that also hate their job
when you convert that to limitation and
create the capacity for 30 40 50 more
positive
bringing positive notice that a lot of
popular voices are just pulling more
negativity on the other side
that's not going to get you there you
having negativity and then you deciding
to deploy negativity isn't solving the
problem it's a short-term good feeling
of like you're not getting punched
anymore but you're punching down okay
but what about like yeah but what about
having a healthy conversation that stops
the punching on either side so my
brother it's about eliminating fear the
way you eliminate fear is by putting in
the work
therapy exercise meditation there's like
a lot of different ways to actually get
there spirituality is exploding because
it's one of the ways right spirituality
amongst young males unheard of when we
were coming up the game sir 25 years ago
a dude talking yeah maybe a far-fetched
hippie somewhere now it's mainstream
people talk about spirituality it's
wonderful and this is an East Meets West
game right this is good we're getting I
see mentality hitting a level of purple
that politics isn't I think we're
starting to take stuff from a India from
a Buddhist from a Asian from a uh
Eastern European like the stuff that
some of the people in my life are doing
around grounding these are the things my
great grandma used to tell me she's like
go outside and take your shoes off and
walk on the grass I'm what the [__] is
going on here or like put onions on your
feet everything's from your feet I'm
like onions on my family all this weird
stuff that seemed like I was like
embarrassed because like no American
friend they were just taking medicine
and like go to the doctor and my
family's like eat this like thing we
just pulled out from the crowd like
Grandma's you know now this is becoming
something that people are starting to
talk about again I like this I think
we're finding the middle and I think for
everyone who's listening find the middle
and that middle is you can't be
delusional but the cynicism and
negativity is just not working for
anyone you tearing down others because
you feel suppressed is not going to work
it's just War it's what can I expand on
that a little please because when you
talk about the elimination of fear I'm a
big proponent that it's a very hippie
and cliche thing to say but love always
wins always right and love is the the
absolute remedy to all fear I always say
love is undefeated 100 it just might be
losing at halftime yes and that's what's
happening right now loves losing in
halftime right now love was losing in
halftime in the 60s like it just it Ebbs
and flows love is just losing at
halftime right now but you're I don't
think it's [__] hippie I think it's
the most practical [__] on Earth hey so
I work with a lot of young men
especially and for a lot of them a very
common theme that I see is that they Don
don't have practical access to
actionable love in their life and so
it's almost like the fear wins by
default at that point so what's your
advice to those people to young people
men and women both I personally work
with more men but I'm sure women feel it
too everyone feels and when it comes to
being a young person you don't have like
a great family you don't have a lot of
support of people around you fine find
your family garyvee find your [__]
family yeah are you kidding me that's
why we love friends so much you pick
those [__]
you picked them I I didn't pick my
brother and sister though I'm very lucky
because I love them both but like and I
have a great Stitch but I know a lot of
people that don't like we pick our
friends
and by the way [__] changes too I love
loyalty do you know much I love loyalty
I [__] love loyalty I'm still a
Jetson Knicks fan I [__] with loyalty
but if your friend changes
and you've given everything you got
limiting that is okay too it's it's
fighting for love it's fighting for
positivity and it's putting that on a
pedestal over any other attribute people
put loyalty
above positivity and love and I love and
I love it because I respect it it's like
such a beautiful right I think we all
[__] with people that are loyal but if
you're loyal and you don't realize
you're the alpha you're the beta and
your loyalty is continuing to drive you
into negativity because you're being
loyal to a negative energy you're not
being loyal you're being an enabler to
bad behavior
do you know any people right now think
they're being loyal but what they
actually are are enablers to toxic
Behavior you're enabling your sister to
continue to complain if you stop letting
her complain [__] will change
now I want to do just a couple little
ones on the way out no I mean anything
stand out any other question anything
like I know we went very heavy there
anything as simple as like what should I
do on Tick Tock stories or like I know
I'm like anyway because I feel so bad
um no no this is It's don't this is what
I love about it nothing's bad yeah we
went heavy but now let's go like what
should I price my nails at 1999 or 20.
like this is what this is I'm really
glad you just said that because I think
there's a moment for me to tell people
nothing's bad you can go heavy I feel
it's comfortable talking about like
world love as I do two seconds later
trying to sell a Pokemon card on eBay
yeah I don't think that's beneath me
just because I did that or that's bad
because I just did that everything is
acceptance for me it's all okay
it's all okay if it's good intent yeah
you you know bad intent you're not
saying how do I rip people off sell them
nails and never ship it to them you're
saying you know what I mean you're
saying like hey I've got like like these
are all and by the way here's a big one
if you if you feel yourself you're not
going to fulfill anyone else
one of the reasons I'm so capable of
like bringing good to others is because
I'm bringing good to myself
yeah it's so funny because I feel like
my whole theme all the time especially
lately I don't know why is very much oh
I'm scared they're gonna be mad at me
like when this podcast comes out and my
clients here I want to step away from
Nails I'm gonna be they're gonna be
devastated and I'm like can I say
something Katie just even known you for
a little bit a lot of them are gonna be
happy for you yes honestly right and
you're so sweet you don't want to
disappoint them and you know what's
funny about me I got to do a better job
in the next chapter of my life I make a
lot of silly jokes or say unique things
but they're actually very serious when I
said earlier to you you should be like
the Rock and come out of retirement and
do WrestleMania I actually mean that yes
imagine if you said hey I'm doing this
if this goes well
uh for you 20 how many clients would you
say are sitting in your stomach of like
oh they're gonna be mad like just give
me a number dude only like I know three
exactly you know no I knew it yeah and
it's you see them in your head and
you're like um
so once a year come out of retirement
for the three do a spot like a whole day
and [__] do their nails like they've
never been done before if I can have
dinner do you know what I mean yeah like
you could really take care of that
totally you see where I'm going yeah and
now we've just put that on we're good
now those three ladies we're gonna [__]
and by the way you can do it once a
quart you could be once a quarter it
doesn't even have to be once again you
can do it once a quarter yeah obviously
they're gonna have to find somebody else
if they're doing it more often but you
do dinner with them once you're just
like up they're gonna be happy for you
yes totally and it's funny even like the
transition from doing nails and posting
nails and building my platform on based
on people being like oh I can't wait to
see what nails you did and then
switching from hey I am selling this
kind of stuff now I'm like they're gonna
be so mad at me like that it's such it's
so funny it's such a theme and it's just
like I'm proud of you you love your
community but you can't fear your
transition
I know I get it well guess what
sometimes you know one thing I really
believe in is like this was supposed to
happen three years ago I the meaning but
maybe it was supposed to happen today
for you but the fact that it happened in
2020 it was just very interesting it hit
me I was like oh no this is something I
really like and I really enjoy you can't
you can't not follow your light yeah
because you have nice love to three
ladies yeah you can't do that yes I know
it sounds silly but it's good to talk
through yes but even like the followers
you know like even though you're staying
in a general pocket oh by the way yes as
my team knows I'm doing wine content a
little bit here and there lately too
like you know in a year you might want
to do it again like once in a while and
film it like and there's no absolutes in
this yeah what do you got brother
similar kind of what you're talking
about right now so I have a tendency to
like I'm gonna write a book now I'm
gonna do I'm just going to start a tech
company I'm doing this attorney stuff
then I'm gonna do this consulting stuff
and I want to do all the things all at
once good and um I obviously dropped
balls too yeah I want to know like if
you have a process for picking the balls
back up so like picking this back up yep
or if it just naturally flows in like a
year down the line it's like all right
you know I want to pick that up again
more of the latter however that as I
became bigger financially it allowed me
to have more infrastructure around me I
used to make content by myself
I used to do my own calendar
I used to make strategic Decisions by
myself now I have full two two Office of
the CEOs you know chief of staffs I have
three full-time admins so how big is the
team said about 35 people I have 35
people full-time making content with me
like but that was all built over time so
in the beginning it was the latter and
then as I got to a financial place where
I could create infrastructure around me
to keep an eye on some of the things or
help me move them along or project
manage it or double check it or cross
the t's and eyes I did and you will do
the same
building uh big advice for everyone
hiring an admin early who you are
mentoring
to a much bigger position should happen
more too many people hire career admin
thinkers instead of Young Bucks who are
willing to eat crow to do the admin work
just to be close to you because they
want to be somewhat like you or some
version of you or like you
huge opportunity for a lot of people out
there and can really help
brother beautiful so I have to make them
quick first one a lot of what you're
talking about to me when you talk about
eliminating fear
um being in that positive being aware
self-aware yes a lot of that the way it
comes across is very value-based but I'm
a strong believer that there's a big
discipline component too so for people
who are maybe struggling in that process
of discovering themselves finding
Clarity in terms of not allowing the
fear to overwhelm them where's the
balance between things that are
instilled value-wise and things that you
build discipline wise it's a great
question I think you know discipline
look you've got don't worry about the
sound I love this this is how I love it
so don't worry at all thank you so much
sir
um I like the Reel of New York in the
back and trust me this is already going
to be the best sounding podcast we ever
do so like this will be more than fine
that little uh car in the background um
how I think about instill versus
discipline comes in the following I most
of it
I either instilled was instilled in me
or I instilled in myself or I altered A
variation of what was instilled in me as
I started to observe and adjust to life
comma discipline
10 years ago I was like oh crap I am not
in good shape I don't eat well I never
exercise I have no muscles I start to
get a little bit educated here in random
things like your leg muscles are a
direct indication of how long you live
because so many people fall in their 80s
and 90s because of weak legs and
prematurely uh you know speed up the
process of dying and I'm like I don't
[__] want to die and so like you know
like I started this and so 10 years ago
I created discipline around my eating
and workout behavior in the form of
self-awareness and I realized that I
needed a babysitter
not because I needed someone to police
me but because I needed to be
accountable to someone because I'm not
good at being accountable to myself I'm
a good leader because I want to do it
for Dustin and Julian and Sid more than
I want to do it for myself I'm a team
captain
but when it comes to me I never and
still don't want to beat how fast I ran
or pump more iron than like I'm not
competing with myself
I like competing with others and I like
to lead others
so what I needed was a babysitter so I
heard Mike full-time Mike vacanti mainly
because I didn't want to let him down
like it was a weird self-awareness game
that figured out how to create a
discipline around something so you're
not gonna be able to create a discipline
for yourself if you don't understand how
you work I had an epiphany that I'm
better for others than I am for myself
thus bringing someone into my health and
fitness life didn't create the policing
that it sounds like I needed someone to
be my full-time Trader sounds like
someone needs to be my babysitter it was
the reverse I needed to make someone
proud I needed to come through for
someone I needed to be accountable to
someone
was a game changer I think for a lot of
people listening here if you can figure
out your framework
then you can deploy it and that's what I
did there beautiful beautiful last
question is if we ran 365 back again
could we get the garyvee cosign a
hundred percent you get to all 365 at
the end we'll make sure on a vlog we
give a hardcore cosign pick four or five
songs to integrate into that Vlog the
teams right here watching you get to
that number and do a 2024 365 or a half
if you start tomorrow and do it a full
year you don't have to do a calendar you
can do it continuous we're about that
done
my friends thank you where can everyone
find you let's go Katie nail thoughts
like as in thinking about Nails on
Instagram YouTube and everything yep yep
colindar.com
c-o-l-i-n-d-a-r-k-e and that's my handle
on all the socials all the music is
Juicy druc Instagram is Jedi Alchemist I
love it Vader Nation give me a lot of
feedback on this platform this kind of
genre do you want more podcasts like
this love you Serge thank you we'll see
you next time
[Music]
gotta keep it light up in my suitcase
all around the world and back maybe in a
few days I'm Dreaming wake up doing
battle again can't take a flight but I
can fight and learn to travel within
just take a breath